in this video we'll talk about the
complement system and the associated
disorder this is for USMLE step one and
this is a high yield video so stay tuned
till the end complement proteins are set
of proteins that cooperate between init
and adaptive immune system to eliminate
pathogens like bacteria
so these complement proteins are
generated by the liver and they
comprises about 15 percent of the
globulin protein in the plasma
so how does complement protein works at
very simple level these are bunch of
proteins that assemble on the membrane
of the bacteria and form a membrane
attack complex and thereby it allows
leakage of fluid from the bacteria and
the bacteria burst this is how
complement system works now there are
different Pathways of complement
activation very briefly there are three
pathways the lectin pathway and the
classical pathway starts differently
so the lectin pathway starts with Manos
binding lectin which recognizes the
sugar mighties on the plasma membrane
and the classical pathway is based on
antigen antibody interaction and it also
requires the protein known as c1q
now in the classical pathway there are
complement proteins C2 and C4 which get
cleaved by these membrane complex and
forms c4b and c2b so all these c4b and
c2b together form the enzyme known as C
to B and c4b which is also known as C3
converters and this enzyme is really
important C3 converters convert C3 as
the name suggests into c3a and c3b
further c3b get associated with these
membrane Association and form the C5
converters C5 converters is a crucial
player in the complement pathway
C5 convert is converts C5 into C5 a and
C5 B all these C5 a c3a they can work
like potential in aflatoxin
then further c5b
can embed itself into the membrane and
attract further complement proteins like
C6 to C8
eventually it forms the membrane attack
complex which is basically several rings
of C9 protein and this leads to fluid
leakage from the membrane and these pore
leads to lysis of the bacteria now this
was basically the classical pathway
now lectin dependent pathway Works via
masp one C2 and C4 it converge at the
level of C3 converters so many Pathways
actually converge at the level of C3 and
C5 converters such as the alternative
pathway alternative pathway requires
factors like Factor d b or period so
they all converge into C3 converters or
otherwise C5 converters
ultimate goal is to create the membrane
attack complex and lead to fluid leakage
now complement system can also decorate
the bacteria with complement protein and
this is known as opsonization
so these opsonized bacteria can be
engulfed by several uh
phagocytotic cells such as macrophages
or let's say tendritic cell
and this phagocytosis is triggered by
several receptors present on the surface
of these cells such as cr1 complement
receptor 3 cr4 FC receptor Etc
but have you ever wondered why does host
cells are unaffected by complement
system why membrane attack complex does
not form on the surface of a host cell
because there are specific inhibitory
proteins present in the host cells that
prevents complement mediated attack this
is how the the host cell prevent any
kind of collateral damage during
complement fixation now let's talk about
the complement efficiencies
so the early complement deficiency is
basically deficiency in the protein
complements C1 to C4
major deficiency occurs at C3 and when
C3 is not available the initial part of
the complement system is messed up this
lead to and increase the chances of
recurrent pyogenic infection in the
respiratory tract infection
so there are other problems
c3b and this C3 convert is enzyme
complex cannot form
as a result uh the complement fixation
is not happening
and it also increases the risk of
systemic lupus
there are other deficiencies such as
terminal complement deficiencies where
the proteins of C5 to C9 are
nine could be deficient that increases
the susceptibility of nyseria bacteremia
so you can understand that for any of
these complement deficiencies there is a
common theme recurrent bacterial
infection because these proteins are
necessary to kill bacteria and when
there is a deficiency in this protein
obviously there would be bacterial
infection and more chance of bacterial
infection
C1 esterase inhibitor deficiency is
another type of complement deficiency
which causes hereditary angioedema and
it leads to upregulation of cow cream
and bradykinin it leads to edema in
different regions especially in the
facial portions
also there is another deficiency known
as
paroxysmal nocturnal hemoglobin
hemoglobinuria
so in this particular
deficiency what happens is a particular
x-linked Gene known as phosphatidyl
inositol glycan Class A or Pig a
which gets mutated
so it actually produces a GPI anchor
protein so when this GPI anchor protein
is not produced it leads to problem
proteins that are responsible for
regulation of complement activity such
as cd55 cd59 are thereby preventing from
attaching to the cell surface that means
overall complement system is hyperactive
and dysregulated
this leads to fixation of complement on
RBC surfaces lead to lysis of these
cells so that leads to uh hemolytic so
hemolytic effect and anemia can also be
a result of this kind of situation
so all the complement efficiency is
summarized in this table you can pause
this video and get a quick overview of
these uh diseases
if you need more flash cards and notes
you can go to my Facebook page or
Instagram
you can support our Channel using super
thanks see you in next video